Speaker 1: So we have a new but somewhat
predictable wrinkle in the entire discussion
that's now happening around the Democrats
infrastructure bill, social spending bill
and this debate that's happening not only
between Democrats and Republicans, but also
within Democrats trying to bring Senators Joe
Manchin and Kirsten Sinema on board with getting
something passed at some point relatively soon.
The new wrinkle is that there are reports that
Joe Manchin is considering leaving the Democratic
Party, which Joe Manchin has immediately denied
and said RBC, which to me doesn't really mean
much at all and is almost predictable that Joe
Manchin would deny it because just the rumor
floating is probably enough to achieve what one
might imagine Joe Manchin would want to achieve
by threatening to leave the Democratic Party,
which is to push Democrats to say, Whoa,
whoa, whoa, OK, OK. It's sort of like
some people are having an argument. One person
pulls out a gun and everybody, Whoa, whoa, OK,
no, you're you're good. You're good. So let's talk
about it. First of all, the report is in Mother
Jones by David Corn. David Corn has a good track
record. I tend to believe that at least David
Corn's report is believable now. Whether someone
lied to David Corn. OK, you could talk about that
20 hours ago. Scoop Manchin tells associates he's
considering leaving the Democratic Party and has
an exit plan. He could pull the trigger if he
doesn't get his way on the build back better bill.
In recent days, Joe Manchin has told associates
that he's considering leaving the Democratic
Party of President Joe Biden and Democrats
on Capitol Hill do not agree to his demand
to cut the size of the social infrastructure bill,
basically in half from three point five trillion
to one point seventy five trillion, according
to people who have heard Manchin discuss this.
Manchin has said if this were to happen, he would
declare himself an American independent, not a
Republican. And he has devised a detailed exit
strategy for his departure. This is a little too
detailed to imagine it's all made up. I'll give
you my thought as to what is actually going on,
Manchin told Associates. He has a two
step plan for exiting the party. First,
he would send a letter to Senator
Chuck Schumer, the top Senate Democrat,
removing himself from the Democratic leadership
of the Senate. He's vice chair of Senate Democrats
Policy and Communication Committee. Manchin hopes
that would send a signal. He would then wait and
see if that move has any impact on negotiations.
After about a week, he said he would change his
voter registration from Democrat to independent.
Now, here's the key question about all of this.
It is unclear whether, in this scenario, Manchin
would end up caucusing with the Democrats,
which would allow them to continue to control the
Senate or side with the Republicans in place, the
Senate in Republican hands. In either event, he
would hold great sway over this half of Congress.
Look at the way in which this guy is now able to
essentially hold hostage the Democratic Party,
not only when it comes to the infrastructure bill,
but even within control of the Senate, because
understand that the the majority for Democrats
right now in the Senate is Kamala Harris. It's
50 50, 50 Democrats, 50 Republicans. In terms
of caucusing Bernie and Angus King, independents
caucus with Democrats and Kamala Harris as
the tie breaking vote in the cases of 50 50.
If Joe Manchin does this routine but says No,
I'm like Bernie and Angus King, I caucus with
Democrats. You still essentially have a 50-50
situation. This is regardless of how Manchin
votes on any individual bill important to keep in
mind if Manchin no longer caucuses with Democrats,
you have a 51 49 majority for Republicans,
and now Mitch McConnell takes control and
has sway over what is even a discussion in the
Senate a dramatically different situation now.
As I mentioned earlier, Joe Manchin very
quickly denied this. He said the report
is B.S. period and said, I have no control
over the rumors, but it's B.S. for all we know.
Joe Manchin arranged to have the rumor floated
himself because even the rumor alone is a threat.
It's a threat. And whether whether he's
really thinking about doing it or not,
putting this out there can serve to pull Democrats
over into being more, you know, into placating him
more than they already have. But ultimately,
what this comes down to is does this guy in
the long term caucus with Democrats or not? He's
not saying he might become a Republican, although
in basically every state, but West Virginia, he's
a Republican, quite frankly. And. The potential of
the gavel going back to Mitch McConnell is a real
threat, so it's on the one hand, maybe a carefully
crafted move to threaten this in this way and then
deny it. On the other hand, it is a real threat. I
mean, we can't you know, when when Bill we spoke
to Bill Scherrer on Tuesday on the show and Bill
Sr. said, you know, for all the arguments about
primary him or not or this, that the other thing,
if it weren't for Joe Manchin being a Democrat,
if Joe Manchin were a Republican or if Joe Manchin
was replaced with a Republican, there's not even
the possibility of this bill. It is just dead.
And so. He does have the sway that at the end
of the day, we can say this guy should not have
the power that he has, and I'm right there with
you. I'm the one who said in the first week after
the November 2020 election, Joe Manchin is going
to have a lot of power in this upcoming Senate,
but I don't see the solution being kick him out
of the Democratic Party or primary him, which
probably leads in West Virginia to a Republican
winning. The only solution is win more seats. Now,
if you lose Manchin but gain two seats or three
seats or four seats, you've still got a majority.
OK. But just just saying, let's figure out how to
get rid of Joe Manchin. It just doesn't check out
mathematically. And the problem is, Democrats
don't have more seats at the end of the day. So
we'll see how this what what happens. But Joe
Manchin denying the rumor, I don't think I would
put too much weight into that because of all the
reasons we mentioned. Let me know what you think.